sauf que quand on va à la critique et
qu'elle faudra pas qu'elles viennent
pleurer il faut pas que l'âge la faune
vous dites qu'elle attaque de l'ormeau
et kelly faut pas attaquer les gens
parce que si et quand on va t'attaquer
toi c'est la première à venir pleurer la
première à 0 mds
on m'a dit ça m'a touchée ça m'a peiné
faut pas alors ça c'est ce qu'elle a
fait c'est pas bon mathieu mathieu
delormeau mathieu ben bardon mais j'ai
l'impression que vous débarquez un petit
peu tous et j'étais quand même l'un des
premiers à le dire on y pense vraiment
que karine le marchand est une fille
gentille je pense que karine lemarchand
d'abord méprise totalement la plupart
des agriculteurs lorsqu'il y va avec ses
talons et qu'elle paie les fausses
interviews gentille je pense qu'elle a
pas une once d'empathie à la de
l'empathie pour la chaîne mais pas du
tout pour l'émission et pour le reste
c'est pas la première fois qu'elle est
dans des clichés elle a effectivement
tacler kelly parce qu'elle est ainsi à
fait qu'elle est blonde elle m'a taclé
mois dans une émission parce qu'elle m'a
traitée de sombre idiot
là elle tacle ribéry et même que ribéry
une bête caillou parents fous attaques
de ribéry parce que c'est un fou de
bonheur voilà il se trouve que karine
marchand depuis le début mais pardon
renseignez vous un petit plombier c'est
important sur les gens souvent qui sont
derrière les caméras derrière les
équipes là karine le marchand
on aime ou on n'aime pas ce n'est pas
une qui très sympathique et c'est une
fille je trouve qui a tendance à
mépriser beaucoup de monde et le dire de
plus en plus parce qu'elle a un petit
phénomène de sur poids parce qu'elle
finition qui fait digne en
téléspectateurs n'ont maintenant ils
savent ou non ils sont libres ils ont un
ennemi maladroit et finalement
d'effectivement et on se permet un petit
peu tout elle méprise totalement les
gens j'étais l'un des premiers à dire et
de ne trouver que même également ses
interviews de 2,2 d'agriculteurs été
fait dans le mépris de ce petit côté
parisien en rigolant voilà moi comment
karine lemarchand maintenant c'est
uniquement à m sila qui me fait rire
qu'on le rire les méprisants